yeah welcome to this video playing GH
981 from the US I guess there's no yes
sometimes you have those flags that are
quite similar to well-known one ok I
played out this reversed Grand Prix
which is some yeah quite a playable
opening mmm trip to g5 yeah should i
provoke him yeah probably ok let's take
the chance to inflict a slight damage to
his pawn structure but my one it's not
such a big deal really the bee father
says something yes still this is some oh
this is strange this is this really we
can see form and not really am it's not
really clear what this actually
accomplishes deform ok lets them get out
of this there's always ideas with checks
on d5
yeah how to play that I have fun slide
coordination problems this is the only
only issue I need if I got one or two
extra moves and he's playing this a bit
too quickly to be honest i know i'm
often telling that but then he needs to
play now exact moves otherwise i will be
a much better because of the pawn
structure looks like III is just just
too indifferent probably okay Bishop to
d7 95 95 is the normal rules probably I
want to play Bishop a six and pressurize
the pawn yeah this is why I was
hesitating but Bishop a six should be a
good move anyway because I have ideas to
go to eat or d3 depending where he's
going yep exactly this I was thinking
about
and now closed the position this was the
idea
so with that I have a night against
bishop and I'm in a fairly close
position at the end i'd like to I'm
threatening dtec c5 now yeah this is
what I wanted to provoke so now I have
the C file open and i have c 3 as a
ready-made point of attack and he cannot
attack some something in my porn
structure at least they don't see it at
the moment can increase with rook c8
yeah maybe he can try to two sec the
exchange question is some I could but
it's not a great idea i am and just play
96 what i was thinking about okay let
him sex the exchange whatever
it doesn't need to take but I thought
this was the idea yep Queenie 60m
attacking or wait wait wait why Cannot
why what can a lot to take I came at the
end him he's taking a 7 hmm oopsie one
maybe this is a good move attacking this
and in this i also have Queen h5 here so
let's say at one point night see for
Bishop takes rook checks and then I've
got Queen h5 f3 on the light squares yep
and let's grab now is there reason not
to don't think so
92 to f3 is also an idea if he ignores
all that
and I'm also threatening or intending to
play a d5 if you place queen bee three
or something setting up a pin okay even
then I can play 92 if I want but I
better is d5 just cementing the night on
no sea foam I'm not quite sure what he's
doing at the Mount maybe he really he
didn't see that it was saying oh I know
he doesn't have a really obvious obvious
could move to be honest
so just d5 is this good was 92 to f3 a
good thing and just let's just cement
this piece should be good
what is this next movie he doesn't
really have a great move I'm even
wondering about all those looks here
what exactly is happening on this taking
on b6 yeah shrine forms for counter
check now here on the second rank
yeah they can give this take age six but
this is really just the check in I
should have some some play against his
King King as well Ruby 30 f3 or
something
if the bishop ever leaves this
diagonally to to h5 I have Queen h5 f3
let's say Bishop f1 ok looks weird
anyway but Queen age 5 then that's a
good move until only has one check em
check
just taking him I guess o Queen there
oops ah mmm I didn't didn't consider
this at all shoot but it's just the
checkya
yeah it says I think it's it's just a
couple of checks check our way to check
here check
hmm
time morning I'm little nonsense but I
oh my god check check check check check
check check black for fits on time yeah
oh you'll still need to pay attention
even if you feel this is even winning
for white can you believe that yet this
actually you just do to do to h5 what
this losses unbelievable of course looks
it to immediately stronger yes I am now
in this term probably everything winds
but yeah as shouldn't play a success is
a bad decision on a blitz game it's
winning of course it's winning but it
makes things complicated in this
position here he basically has no moves
I can play all kinds of strengthening
movie of g5 I mean he has no moves can
only take on c4 and exchange of 22 dead
end games and this really am is six this
is a bad practically like that practical
decision it still total hopefully
winning but I need to play more
precisely now and
this losers is really cool yeah I mean
he certainly wasn't aware that he's
winning now but I mean yeah this is
really over Jack nothing I can do now
just just terrible what I did them
losing this position is really a shame
yeah well what can you do thanks for
watching